Speaker 1: All right.
The Joe Biden presidency has done a complete
180.
It is stunning the degree to which the Biden
presidency has turned around.
Think back to two and a half or so months
ago.
No major no major recent accomplishments for
Joe Biden.
Approval rating in Trump's favorite place
in the toilet.
The third element of the bathroom, not looking
good for November.
The reelection of Joe Biden, a seeming impossibility
based on the direction things were going.
But then we started to put together a bunch
of different things that took place.
And from further back, we had, of course,
getting out of Afghanistan, which was an absolutely
fantastic decision.
Did it go perfectly?
No, it went about as well as it would have
if Trump had done it.
But we're out of Afghanistan.
We now have Joe Biden's student loan forgiveness
package, which is a major deal and I believe
will absolutely help Democrats in November.
We had an incredible July jobs report.
About a quarter million jobs were expected.
More than half a million jobs were actually
created.
Wages are up.
Inflation is down.
Gas prices have been steadily coming down.
And significantly, we've had the PACT Act
signed.
The Inflation Reduction Act has been signed.
We've got the older infrastructure bill, which
Biden did.
And then on the other side, look at what's
happening for the right wing.
The revelations from the January six committee
disastrous.
Disastrous for Trump and people around him,
completely bonkers MAGA nominees.
We'll talk about Laura Loomer after the break.
Just cartoonish, nuts running, Herschel Walker,
Doug Mastriano, all these people.
Roe v Wade overturned something the right
has wanted for so long.
Absolutely horrifying.
Trump busted with documents at his house,
and now we learned the number of documents
is in the hundreds.
And it's all completely crazy.
And meanwhile, the Republican civil war is
growing.
We're in.
Donald Trump is now calling for the removal
and replacement of Mitch McConnell as the
Republican leader in the Senate.
Currently, the Senate minority leader probably
will remain in the minority after the November
midterms.
What an incredible turnaround for Joe Biden
and what an incredible contrast to what's
going on on the Republican side.
No policy ideas.
They haven't had policy ideas for years.
Remember the health care plan that was weeks
from coming out in the summer of 2020 and
then we never got the health care plan because
there is no health care plan, no policy.
Just get in the way of Democrats.
That's it.
The Civil War, the absolutely brazen nature
with which they just lie and lie, lie and
tell the same lies over and over again, including
about the 2020 election.
There could be no greater contrast right now,
but the contrast alone wouldn't be that notable.
The two month turnaround of the Biden presidency
has been stunning.
Now, will it make a difference in November?
Because it looks like Democrats probably will
keep the Senate but lose the House.
Can something different happen in the House?
If Democrats were able to keep the House and
Senate in November.
It would be historic, given what normally
happens in midterms after a new party takes
the White House.
Incredible.
Let me know your thoughts.
And all the clips we played in these segments
will be on our Instagram if you want to check
them out.
Search Instagram for David Pakman show and
also find me on Instagram at David Pakman.
Check out some of my pictures from the last
week in Canada and I will tell some stories
on the bonus show about that as well.